I also asked Gates where he lands on the topic we talk about...
....virtually every day in this program:
Bitcoin, and how he thinks about the cryptocurrency in the context of climate change...
...seeing as how Bitcoin takes enormous amounts of energy to digitally mine.
I don't own Bitcoin.
I'm not short Bitcoin.
So, I've taken a neutral view.
I do think moving money into a more digital form and getting transaction cost down,...
...that's something the Gates Foundation does in developing countries.
But there, we do it so that you can reverse the transactions...
...so you have total visibility of who's doing what,...
...so it's not about tax avoidance or illegal activity.
But, Bitcoin can go up and down just based on the mania or whatever the views are...
...and I don't have a way of predicting how that will progress.